c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soit il est bienvenu sur France 24 à la
une ce soir le Mali qui interdit les
activités des ONG financées par la
France les militaires au pouvoir l'ont
annoncé ce lundi dans un communiqué
posté sur les réseaux sociaux nous
serons en direct avec Serge Daniel dans
ce journal le président kenyan à
Kinshasa William Routot s'est entretenu
avec son homologue congolais Félix
Tshisekedi la réaffirmé le rôle
important de son pays le Kenya dans le
processus de paix dans l'est de la
République démocratique du Congo une
région où les combats se poursuivent
entre l'armée congolaise et la milice du
ham-23 correspondance à Kinshasa dans ce
journal et puis la Coupe du monde de
football un début de compétition raté
pour le Sénégal qui s'incline face au
Pays-Bas début à zéro pour les Bataves
mauvaise opération pour les Lions de la
Téranga retour sur cette rencontre avec
elon toblet notre chroniqueur sport du
au journal de l'Afrique
c'est l'information de ce lundi soir les
militaires au pouvoir au Mali ont
annoncé l'interdiction des activités des
ONG financées par la France Serge Daniel
journalistes RFI est en ligne avec nous
Serge bonsoir toutes les ONG financées
par la France sont concernés y compris
celles opérant dans le domaine
humanitaire
à destination de du Mali et prenant
cette décision la France avait précisé
quelle se justifiait face à l'attitude
de la jeune malienne à Lyon mercenaires
russes de wagnais qui sont pour
plusieurs pays européens au Mali alors
ce lundi le gouvernement malien a
qualifié la décision de Paris
d'alégation fantaisistes avant
d'annoncer qu'il interdit désormais sur
son territoire toutes les activités
menées par les ONG opérant au Mali
sufinancement ou a pu matérielle ou
technique de la France il faut quand
même ajouter que ca Paris avait pris
cette décision il y a une quinzaine de
ONG qui est dans un communiqué avait dit
non attention il faut pas le faire parce
que l'aide est nécessaire vous avez 7,5
millions de maniés qui ont besoin
d'assistance soit plus de 35% de la
population
oui les conséquences sont nombreuses
merci beaucoup Serge Daniel pour votre
décryptage la rencontre entre William
Routot et Félix Tshisekedi le président
kenyan s'est déplacé ce lundi à Kinshasa
pour évoquer la situation à sécuritaire
dans l'est de la République démocratique
du Congo il a réaffirmé sa volonté de
mener à bien les pourparler de paix les
discussions entre les différents
belligérants qui devaient se tenir un
aérobie ont été reportés à la fin de la
semaine en attendant les combats se
poursuivent dans le Nord qui veut et la
menace plein toujours sur Goma la
correspondance à Kinshasa d'Aurélie
bazarra kibangula
plusieurs sources locales nous affirment
que les combats ont repris ce lundi dans
le groupement de Tongo dans le
territoire de ruchourou un calme
précaire règne en revanche sur le front
sud à kibomba une localité située à une
vingtaine de kilomètres de Goma qui a
été le théâtre d'affrontement ce weekend
entre les rebelles du M23 et les forces
armées congolaises mais selon le colonel
jkiko Guillaume la situation reste sous
contrôle la population de Goma garde son
calme son armée travaille et se comporte
très bien sur le terrain des opérations
donc il est important que la population
sache que elle doit
aider son armée
à repousser cette ennemi mais aussi elle
doit résister face à la dresseur les
habitants redoutent une nouvelle attaque
du M23 l'arrivée d'une centaine de
soldats Kenyans la semaine dernière sur
un total de 900 hommes attendus à créer
beaucoup d'espoir lors de sa première
visite ce lundi à Kinshasa le président
Kenya William Routot affirmé devant la
presse que le Kenya va pleinement jouer
son rôle pour tenter de ramener la paix
dans l'Est de la RDC et il a insisté les
troupes Kenya notamment
privilégiée reste donc pour l'heure la
voie politique de son côté le président
congolais Félix Tshisekedi a affirmé une
fois de plus que son pays fait face je
cite à une agression injuste et barbare
du voisin rwandais la reprise des
pourparlers de Nairobi avec les groupes
armés est annoncé pour le dimanche 27
novembre et Kinshasa refuse toujours de
discuter avec le M23 avant le retrait du
groupe rebelle bonne qualité occupées le
M23 est d'ailleurs considéré comme un
groupe terroriste par les autorités
congolaises
et pendant ce temps les populations
continuent à fuir les violences et les
réfugiés continuent à affluer à gommage
chef-lieu du Nord qui vous ils sont
désormais des dizaines de milliers sans
compter ceux qui sont encore bloqués
dans des zones de combat Laurent Berchet
tout juste sorti de la salle d'opération
fouraha twizérée est encore sous le choc
la jeune femme a été transportée
d'urgence dans cette clinique de Goma
après que son village a été pris
d'assaut par les rebelles du M23
[Musique]
mais j'ai beaucoup de blessures sur la
jambe droite
la Croix Rouge a essayé de m'emmener à
l'hôpital mais les soignants étaient en
train de s'enfuir
à son arrivée à la clinique le personnel
soignant découvre que fouraha est
enceinte de jumeaux impossible de la
soigner avant d'effectuer une césarienne
une opération délicate mais finalement
menée à bien par les médecins
déjà débordé face à la flux de réfugiés
ces derniers craignent que le pire ne
soit encore à venir
la zone de conflit mais qu'ils
n'arrivent pas de passer le Frontline
pour arriver ici
nous avons aussi reçu des informations
que il y a de structures de santé qui
ont été pieds après une brève académie
samedi les combats ont repris de plus
belles dans le Nord qui vous les
violences sont déjà fait des dizaines de
milliers de déplacés dans l'Est de la
RDC
voilà ce que l'on pouvait dire sur la
situation dans l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo élection
présidentielle et générale en Guinée
équatoriale elles se sont tenues ce
dimanche les résultats n'ont pas encore
été publiés mais la victoire des députés
sénateurs du parti de toi des héros
obiangles sont assurés d'être reconduits
le président sortant au pouvoir de
picard3 ans devrait lui aussi sans
surprise être réélu théodoro Biang
détient le record mondial de la
longévité au pouvoir
et on vous parle de football avec cette
rencontre Sénégal Pays-Bas un terrible
dénouement pour le Sénégal qui s'est
incliné début à zéro de but qui aurait
pu être évité pour le champion d'Afrique
en titre et l'homme taublé notre
chroniqueurs sport et revenu pour nous
sur cette rencontre
le Sénégal Yaku jusque à la 84e minute
avec le but de Cody Gapeau dans les
derniers instants finalement parce que
on peut dire que le Sénégal faisait jeu
égal on y croyait plutôt le Sénégal
avait plutôt les bonnes occasions pour
prendre le devant mais finalement il y a
ce but de Cody Gapeau qui qui intervient
comme un coup de poignard finalement
pour tous les Sénégalais on ressent leur
douleur ce soir et ce but donc qui fait
que le Sénégal est mené et les
Sénégalais vont pousser dans les
dernières minutes pour essayer au moins
de ramener le match nul et c'est là que
on va voir là on le voit on le voit là
l'image le deuxième but de Davy la scène
sur ce ballon mal repoussé par voilà par
le père Édouard Mendy donc défaites très
cruel pour le Sénégalais et d'ailleurs
on peut aller sentir en fait voilà
l'ambiance à Dakar après cette défaite
qui ne passe pas pour nos amis
sénégalais
[Musique]
on est derrière vous les lions on est
derrière vous c'est pas encore fini
c'est pas encore fini le foot c'est
comme ça il faut gagner
alors c'est pas encore fini quelle est
la suite du programme pour pour les
lions alors la suite du programme pour
les lions ce sera le 25 novembre
prochain à 14h ils vont jouer le pays
haute le Qatar alors c'est jamais facile
de jouer le pays haute même si sur le
premier match on a vu que le Qatar a été
dominé dans les plus grandes largeurs
par l'équateur donc 25 novembre
Qatar Sénégal à 14h puis ensuite le
mardi 29 novembre Équateur Sénégal à 16h
donc c'est les deux derniers matchs pour
les Sénégalais pour essayer de rêver
encore à une qualification
gros problème c'est que en plus de la
défaite aujourd'hui il y a eu deux
blessures qu'il faudra surveiller et
d'avoir celle de
alors celle de Abdoulaye Diallo 62e
latéral gauche titulaire qui est sorti
sous blessure et surtout chez kukuyate
sur les images vu comment ça se présente
on a presque l'impression qu'il ne
pourra pas continuer le tournoi ce sera
une grosse paire pour le Sénégal parce
que ce milieu-là est un milieu
d'expérience qui permettait aussi au
Sénégal en l'absence de voilà de Sadio
Mane comme on a pu le voir dans le vox
pop d'exister et là le Sénégal un peu
d'eau mur mais on espère vraiment que
nos amis sénégalais vont réagir et
pouvant faire mieux pour pour la suite
du tournoi et ce soir nous recevons une
légende vivante de la poésie et la
chanson kabyle Lounis Aït Menguellet
plus d'un demi-siècle de carrière après
avoir célébré ses 50 ans en 2017 au
Zénith de Paris il est de retour à
l'accord Arena et il est avec nous sur
ce plateau ce soir pour parler de ce
concert qui se tiendra ce samedi 26
novembre merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sur ce plateau lonica alors
merci d'autant que vous êtes discret
timide vous n'êtes pas forcément habitué
au plateau télévisions merci infiniment
de nous faire l'honneur d'être ici vous
allez donner donc ce concert ce samedi
partagé vos plus belles chansons il y
aura-t-il des surprises comment va se
présenter ce concert
enfin
certainement de la manière
dont sera organisé le concert
sinon
en matière de chanson
il n'y a il n'y aura pas de surplus donc
ce sera votre répertoire qui sera repris
vous estimez à combien les chansons que
vous avez écrit les poèmes que vous avez
écrit est-ce que vous avez une idée
c'est vrai que parce que je ne tiens pas
vraiment le compte
se nommé enfin dans les deux sont entre
200 et 250 chansons
disons en gros quoi et comment vous vous
voyez votre carrière aujourd'hui après
plus de 50 ans de carrière comment vous
l'analysez rétrospectivement est-ce
qu'il y a des choses que vous auriez
fait autrement ou est-ce que vous ne
regrettez rien
je préfère dire que je ne regrette rien
parce que en fait c'est vrai il y a
toujours des choses qu'on aurait pu
faire autrement mais bon vu les
circonstances vu les contextes
ça n'aurait pas pu être fait autrement
vous avez beaucoup écrit de chansons sur
la Kabylie sur le la berbérité est-ce
que ça reste un source une source
d'inspiration aujourd'hui
oui c'est ma source d'inspiration
principale
parce que
parce qu'il le faut parce qu'il le faut
et il n'y a que la chanson qui qui
maintient un petit peu le souffle
bon espérant qu'il y aura autre chose
qu'il y a une la jeunesse montante et
tout sur laquelle on compte beaucoup
sinon la chanson c'est vrai la chanson a
toujours été le
le principal faire de lance de la
culture de notre culture
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'Afrique restée avec nous l'info
continue sur France 24
[Musique]